bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clip la réfraction dans l'univers la
lumière qui peut être représenté comme
une onde ou un flot de particules des
fautes on se déplace toujours dans tous
les milieux à la même vitesse
ainsi la lumière ne se déplace pas plus
vite dans le vide que dans l'air ou dans
l'eau
cependant lorsque la lumière se déplace
dans un matériau relativement dense
comme de l'eau elle va interagir avec
les atomes qui sont présents dans le
milieu est ainsi par des phénomènes
complexes d'interférences liés aux ondes
bien que la vitesse de la lumière en
elle même reste inchangé le faisceau
lumineux va mettre plus de temps à se
déplacer dans l'eau que dans le vide
de cette façon
un faisceau lumineux va se déplacer
selon différentes vitesses en fonction
du milieu dans lequel il se propage dans
l'air par exemple la lumière va se
propager plus rapidement que dans l'eau
imaginons maintenant que l'on envoie un
faisceau lumineux dans un récipient
contenant de l'eau au départ le faisceau
lumineux se propage dans l'air avec une
vitesse plutôt élevé cependant au moment
où il franchit la séparation entre les
deux milieux
le faisceau va ralentir car elle se
propage maintenant dans l'eau en voyons
maintenant ce même faisceau lumineux
mais cette fois ci selon une direction
au blick
au départ le faisceau lumineux se
propageant dans l'air va continuer à la
même vitesse et dans la même direction
mais au moment d'atteindre la séparation
entre l'air et l'eau le bas du faisceau
va entrer dans l'eau en premier et ainsi
va être ralenti tandis que le haut du
faisceau va continuer à la même vitesse
de cette façon la lumière va être déviée
et changer de direction
c'est ce phénomène de déviation de la
lumière quand elle passe d'un milieu un
autre qu'on appelle réfraction on peut
comprendre ce phénomène de réfraction en
imaginant un bâton flottant à la surface
d'une rivière avec le courant la rivière
va entraîner le bout de bois qui va se
déplacer
maintenant si le courant ralentissent
soudainement comme dans le cas de la
lumière qui changeait de milieux en
passant de l'air à l'eau l'extrémité à
droite du bâton va continuer de se
déplacer à la même vitesse mais pendant
ce temps l'extrémité à gauche du bâton
va se déplacer moins vite
cal se situe là où le courant est plus
faible ainsi le courant en créant une
différence de vitesse va faire pivoter
le bâton sur lui même tout comme le
passage de l'air à l'eau faisait dévier
la trajectoire de la lumière en déviant
la trajectoire de la lumière le
phénomène de réfraction provoque des
déformations et des illusions d'optique
par exemple lorsque l'on plonge un objet
dans un verre d'eau la lumière de cet
objet va traverser l'eau puis le verre
et enfin l'air avant de parvenir à nos
yeux
ainsi par des fractions la lumière va
être déviée et on finira par observer
une image de l'objet qui est déformé par
rapport à sa vraie forme la réfraction
donc présentes un peu partout dans notre
quotidien
lorsque l'on regarde des objets
transparent comme du verre ou de l'eau
mais elle peut également se produire
dans l'atmosphère
là où se trouve par exemple des
variations de température en effet
lorsqu'il fait très chaud
l'asphalté des routes se réchauffe ce
qui fait augmenter la température de
l'air environnant
de cette façon l'air en hauteur et plus
froid que l'air qui se situe proche de
la route
or la lumière se propage plus rapidement
dans l'air chaud qui est moins dense que
dans l'air froid suivront alors la
trajectoire d'un rayon lumineux émis par
le ciel au départ ce rayon lumineux qui
se trouve en hauteur va se diriger en
ligne droite relativement lentement et
descendre progressivement mais en se
rapprochant du sol comme il fait de plus
en plus chaud
la vitesse de la lumière va augmenter et
par effraction que faisceau lumineux va
être déviée jusqu'à finir par remonter
ainsi une personne qui se trouverait sur
la route serait en mesure d'observer une
image du ciel tout en regardant la route
vers le bas la route devient alors une
sorte de miroir qui reflète le ciel
c'est ce que l'on appelle un mirage
chaud
si l inverse il faisait très froid la
température proche du sol serait plus
faible qu'en hauteur et ainsi on
observerait un mirage froid c'est-à-dire
une image surélevé de ceux qui se
trouvent à l'horizon le phénomène de
réfraction atmosphérique est également à
la base des turbulences que l'on observe
lorsqu'il fait très chaud ou à l'inversé
lorsqu'il fait très froid du
scintillement des étoiles dont la
lumière traverse les différentes couches
de l'atmosphère avant de nous parvenir
ou encore des déformations que l'on
observe sur la forme du soleil couchant
enfin la réfraction ne s'applique pas
qu'à la lumière
c'est un phénomène qui s'applique à
toutes les ondes ainsi on peut par
exemple observer la réfraction des ondes
sonores
cette rétraction des ondes sonores a par
exemple pour effet que le son a tendance
à se diriger vers le haut là où il fait
plus froid